first day of the season we're heading
out now try to get on some fish
i'm brad keselowski captain of the
fishhawk fishing is always been a lot
more than a job for me I always had
solace to be able to leave land and just
fish to provide for my family so we can
survive prepping the flag getting ready
for a good tuna season hopefully the new
flag will bring us some luck Brad
started made the logo my first mate is
matsan he's just a guy that you can take
out and you can give them orders will do
what you want to do when Brad got the
glossy had called me and said you want
to go to an efficient i drop rate what I
was doing I went right down the boat we
got the boat rigged up brad is a fish
maniac if it has a tail he has a hook
he's just a fishy fishy guy very good
fisherman go check it out looks good
good
here comes up is so
last season I was first made on the
wicked pisser poulsbo style showdown
here we had a little bit of rocky road
in the beginning but then we got it
straight down we did really well
got him oh yeah but we came up just sure
to be in the number one boat
thanks Brad
the exterior is welcome but now I've got
my own boat so Paul and I will be
competitors this season it pulls right
here in front of it
we're just gonna stop by and see what he
said
yeah what do you think about the new
boat the boat looks good looks really
really good man
brad is a remarkable fishermen each of
us have been fishing here for more than
40 years brand i have forgotten more
about fishing than ninety-nine percent
of the people even know what we forgot
Paul and I together last year we should
one be lost by a hundred freaking
dollars i know we got rocket yeah is it
gonna be hard to have Brad not fish with
me
absolutely he's one of my best friends i
need the best fisherman around the
season
rick has very big shoes to fill and I
have to prove that I could still be
successful with a new greenhorn made any
words of wisdom for me Brad words of
wisdom just spray it right you'll catch
a lot of tuna and you'll be fine
that's what we're planning on going I
think with me and Paul it's really
friendly rivalry because I helped him he
helped me
we helped each other and now i have my
own boat one of us will catch more than
the other who will see what happens
we love you guys you're going to catch
it on your gonna be safe and good luck I
good thanks guys
ok we'll go get a beer we get it was a
bitch you got it sounds good good
thank you Matt well yeah it's got a nice
boat huh yeah